[Aplausos]
[Música]
Bienvenidos a diario del mundial el
programa de France 24 donde actualizamos
y analizamos el día a día de la Copa
Mundial de la FIFA Qatar 2022 a
continuación nuestros titulares
el campeón del mundo gana y convence
Francia se recuperó a tiempo goleó a
Australia y dejó Claro que a pesar de
las ausencias quiere defender su corona
tenemos informe de sedoja
se derrumba un grande Argentina no pudo
en su Debut contra Arabia Saudita el
segundo equipo con peor ranking en este
mundial un revés que reconfigura lo
favoritismos y acaba con el que pudo
haberse convertido en el invicto más
largo de la historia del fútbol tenemos
análisis
180 minutos sin goles la jornada de hoy
incluyó dos empates a 0 Dinamarca frente
a túnez primero y después en el México
Polonia un resultado que preserva las
opciones de Argentina
para analizar el acontecer de cada
jornada Contamos con la presencia de
Octavio zas o periodista de la emisora
Blu radio en Colombia bienvenido Octavio
Hola Omar como siempre Un gusto
saludarte y Y de nuevo estar con todos
ustedes Acá en Francia 24 También
aprovecho a darle la bienvenida a
nuestro enviado especial Juan pupiales
quien nos trae todos los detalles de
primera mano de lo que ocurre en Qatar
saludos Juan
Octavio un placer saludarlos desde aquí
en un nuevo día de saco a Mundo de Qatar
2022 Francia pasó el examen el primer
examen sin mañana sin canté sin pamps
sin ningún peor aún sin el Balón de Oro
Karim Benzema el campeón del mundo supo
ensamblar un grupo ganador donde destacó
la asociación entre mbappé y jijiru
empezó en desventaja Y para colmo perdió
a un referente en defensa como Lucas
Hernández pero fue capaz de reaccionar y
golear a Australia 4-1 Juan popiales
está en doha estuvo en ese partido y le
preguntábamos Este es un resultado con
un valor enorme para hombres como yeru
como rabiot como Teo Hernández que
necesitaban esta reivindicación con la
selección no
sí sobre todo para yru es una alegría
inmensa es una gran demostración para
ese hombre que a sus 36 años está
viviendo una segunda juventud con el
Milan había mucho debate cuando Benzema
no se había lesionado sobre qué debería
haber hecho de poner a benze más
comunico delantero como delantero
titular y poner ajiru en el banquillo
finalmente hoy ante esa ausencia de
Benzema yru fue el titular y esta vez a
diferencia de lo que ocurrió en Rusia
2018 cuando fue titular en casi todos
los partidos y no consiguió marcar hoy
hizo un doblete un doblete con un sabor
muy especial para él porque igual a ti
arría enri como el máximo goleador de
leblé además de jibú su compañero en el
mil antiguo Hernández tuvo también una
reivindicación particular en Rusia 2018
Teo dio como su hermano Lucas hoy
lesionado brilló en esa copa mundo y en
esa conquista de ese mundial hoy él
entró desde el banquillo reemplazando a
su lesionado hermano y asistió
inmediatamente a radio para el gol del
empa con Francia fue además una figura
importante Por esa banda izquierda Teo
está viviendo un grandísimo momento
también con el Milan los campeones
vigentes de la serie a es uno de los
capitanes de la de la escuadra
rossonerie y demostró que está en un
buen estado de forma para radio también
fue una reivindicación en el caso de
radio en 2018 él no estuvo por una
rebelión no quiso ir como suplente para
esa copa mundo y demostró que también
pasa por un buen momento en la liga
italiana particularmente con la juve ha
conseguido hacer dobletes tanto en
Champions como en liga sigue demostrando
esa faceta goleadora hoy fue el líder
del centro del campo acompañado por su
Emily por Joe maní y por cama venga y Ah
pues se hizo sentir con ese gol Así que
un partido con un sabor muy especial
para esos tres jugadores y también para
the Champions que puede demostrar como
en este proceso que viene desde Rusia
2018 hay de verdad de un lugar para
todos que demuestren que están en un
buen momento
esta se puede decir que la clave estuvo
en la capacidad de reacción porque bueno
empiezan en desventajas luego pierden a
Lucas Hernández pero digamos No bajan la
cabeza Francia es capaz de proponer y de
voltear el resultado
si sobre todo porque ese golpe ese golpe
que llega para ese gol de Australia que
llega llegando falencias en la defensa
Lucas Hernández pavar por la banda
derecha los dos centrales dos centrales
muy jóvenes que nunca habían jugado un
mundial upa americano y con atey además
sin barán el capitán de la defensa de
los franceses no estaba así que quedan
unas dudas en la defensa pero
rápidamente de la mano de Teo Hernández
y rabió se arregla y se despega un poco
más el pandoraba ya al final descanso
Francia ganaba 2 a 1 algo que da
confianza rabió cuando celebró ese gol
se notó que quería Como mandar también
un mensaje de calma a sus compañeros
estamos vivos no es el fin del mundo el
gol de Australia fue muy temprano Así
que si efectivamente averiguado de haber
llegado al descanso ganando fue algo muy
importante para Francia de Cara a
conseguir sus primeros Tres puntos en
esta copa mundo y Buscar defender esa
Corona que parece algo casi imposible
dado de las últimas ediciones del torneo
Octavio se puede decir que este
resultado es un termómetro que permite
medir la efectividad de los ajustes que
le tocó hacer a the champs luego de
todas estas ausencias sí Y también
digamos la necesidad que tenían estos
jugadores que que explicaba Juan de de
poder mostrarse ellos sabían por ejemplo
en el caso de raviotti en el caso de
Olivier giroud que tenía que pasar
Prácticamente la desgracia Que pasó de
que perdieran a jugadores como Pogba y
Benzema lesionados para ellos tener una
oportunidad en el mundial Y esa
oportunidad se les presenta ambos en el
mejor momento de sus carreras ya lo
decía Juan en el caso precisamente de
Olivier girou que no solo hoy igual a
tierra Henry como el máximo goleador
sino que además el marca gol en un
mundial había estado en todo el mundial
pasado y no había podido marcar gol
olores Por esa razón también es una
digamos esa cárcel encima un peso es
corregir un montón de cosas que tenía el
equipo líder de James y lo otro eumar
categóricamente Francia se saca el peso
de no jugar con Benzema de la cantidad
de docentes y de aún así tener la
jerarquía para golear como haberlo hecho
a un rival débil como Australia que no
está al nivel de los campeones del mundo
un campeón del mundo que no pudo fue
Argentina no pudo con el récord un buen
resultado hoy hubiera representado
alcanzar el invicto más largo de la
historia para una selección pero ahora
había Saudita tenía otros planes Messi
de penal abrió el marcador la nueva
tecnología del bar para detectarlo fuera
de juego terminó con tres goles anulados
para Argentina en media hora de juego y
en el segundo tiempo vino el balde de
agua fría dos goles en 5 minutos que
ensombrecen el panorama de la
albiceleste Juan podemos decir que este
resultado más que producto de una
sorpresa es producto del apego al
planteamiento táctico de Arabia Saudita
durante todo el partido de la disciplina
táctica
Sí una gran muestra de fútbol la que
hizo es renaje el técnico francés el
experimentado técnico francés Con unas
líneas muy adelantadas que sobre todo lo
que yo destacó ese partido es que Arabia
Saudita mantuvo esa filosofía de partido
todo el encuentro vieron que estaban
jugando con fuego con esos tres goles
anulados por estar al límite desde el
fuera de juego y aún así mantuvieron Esa
presión alta la mantuvieron Cuando
comenzó el segundo tiempo y lo notamos
mucho en el terreno de juego Argentina
no jugaba como argentina se estaba muy
asfixiada porque en realidad todo el
juego se estaba desarrollando en muy
pocos metros del campo y eso es fruto de
esa presión de ese estudio del fútbol
saudique hoy puede destacar y brillar
ante el mundo todos los convocados
del Arabia Saudita zona de la liga local
gran parte de ellos son del alquilar y
hoy dejaron una alegría muy importante
para los aficionados a los 10 que hoy
estaban podemos decir que casi 50 y 50
con la afición Argentina que estaban en
el estadio casi 90.000 personas subimos
en ese estadio hablamos con algunos
aficionados saudíes para ellos es un
país vecino concretar que comparte
varios kilómetros de frontera nos decían
algunos venían vinieron en auto y es un
recorrido que para algunos fue solamente
tres horas para ellos fue muy fácil
llegar aquí ya se especulaba con que
iban a jugar casi de locales sea
necesario y estaban de verdad bajo una
alegría que yo creo que nunca habían
gritado un gol con tanta emoción había
momentos por en los que la grada
prácticamente estaba prácticamente era
un unísono y cualquier jugada de los
saudiese celebrado y se gritaba es
obviamente encontrarse con las
emocionados argentinos con los colegas
argentinos que teníamos ahí en la
tribuna de prensa que inmediatamente se
enfrentaron ante un par ante un panorama
que no estaban los cálculos de ninguno
Juan qué margen tiene Argentina para
cambiar ese panorama para tratar de
rescatar alguna Qué herramienta puede
rescatar para tratar de de solventar
este mal comienzo
para mí todo pasa por Argentina de cara
lo que ocurrió Y de lo que hablaremos
más adelante en ese partido entre México
y Polonia para mí México y Polonia se
pegaron un tiro esta noche al no haber
aprovechado algunos de esos dos equipos
en haber sacado tres puntos y haberle
sacado de ventaja a Argentina que en
este momento en ese momento no no suma
ningún punto Argentina va a vivir una
final de nuevo este sábado de nuevo en
el estadio de usain contra México son
quizás dos de las aficiones
latinoamericanas que mayor hemos visto
en cantidad en esta copa mundo la de
Argentina la de México y es especula de
verdad con un gran ambiente para ese
encuentro Argentina pasa todo pasa por
ganar los dos partidos que le quedan
como dijo Leo en el escalón y calma
todavía hay margen con dos victorias
todavía podemos soñar con llegar a los
octavos de final pero claro se vuelve a
cocer en el ambiente ese ese recuerdo de
Rusia 2018 de clasificar como segundos
de grupo y que en un eventual cruce les
toque contra Francia si es que Francia
consigue clasificar la primera del grupo
pero es que Francia ya sabiendo que hoy
ganó y que Dinamarca empató sabiendo que
si Francia le gana a Dinamarca en el
próximo encuentro también del próximo
sábado ya tendrá mucho para clasificar
como primera de grupo hacer que para
Argentina será alguna misión muy
importante asegurar ese primer puesto
del grupo c
Octavio hoy le anularon tres goles
Argentina probablemente dudoso el de
lautaro Martínez
todo esto fue con la nueva tecnología
del bar para detectarlo fuera del lugar
qué Qué papel va a jugar la tecnología
en este Campeonato del mundo Fíjate lo
entendió perfectamente a la vida Saudita
digamos el El offside semiautomático que
se está llevando a cabo ahora en la copa
del mundo le permite tomar ciertos
riesgos a los equipos como jugar con esa
presión alta con las líneas más
adelantadas valga la redundancia Y eso
hizo Arabia Saudita jugando con el
riesgo que eso significaba pero tratando
de ganarle Argentina en ese sentido que
Argentina obviamente al recibir el
segundo gol no solo que recibió Un gol
por parte del rival sino que quedó
grogui y quedó en medio de un shock que
no logró levantarse la tecnología va a
jugar un papel muy pero muy importante
de Argentina se cansó de ir frente al
arco rival en el primer tiempo terminó
agotado por la cantidad de goles
anulados Y eso también significa un
golpe anímico un golpe digamos de
estabilidad porque al saber que no no
podían conseguir el resultado terminaron
golpeándose ellos mismos y en el segundo
tiempo ya les pasa por encima Arabia
Saudita con esos movimientos que hacían
en función de aprovechar la tecnología y
termina quedando en el camino el sueño
de Argentina que no logró levantar la
cabeza la jornada de este martes incluyó
dos empates sin goles el de México ante
Polonia el que se refería Juan
incluyendo un penal errado por
lewandowski ante Memo Ochoa un resultado
que representa un suspiro de alivio para
Argentina Juan podemos decir que México
propuso más Tuvo más argumentos sobre la
mesa
lo que vimos en ese estadio el estadio
974 uno de los estados más populares que
tenemos aquí mientras los aficionados
Estos son saudíes que todavía está
celebrando la victoria del reino frente
a Argentina Perdón son aficionados
tunecinos estamos cerca de una en una
zona muy central de aquí les contaba lo
que hizo México básicamente fue llevar
la iniciativa de este partido
muy corriente durante todo este día
México quiso tener la iniciativa del
partido tener la pelota a Polonia en
ningún momento le interesó La pelota por
haber tenido una línea de cinco atrás en
algún momento con glitch ese es ferrio
de defensa experimentado de Italia y
México lo intentó buscando su juego con
las bandas se notó mucho la ausencia del
Tecatito Corona Hoy casi que al final
Todo estuvo en la espalda de Irving
Lozano qué podemos decir de este partido
de lo que notamos la afición mexicana
también se hizo sentir cantamos Las
mañanitas allá en ese estadio hubo y
obviamente el gran héroe de nuevo en un
mundial como ya lo hizo contra Brasil en
2014 de Memo Ochoa que fue lo que puso a
celebrar a la afición del Tri salvando
ese penalti de lewandowski y
consiguiendo un punto que para mí se
queda muy corto como decía antes para
ambos equipos porque para mí hoy era una
jornada clave para ambos para sacarle
ventaja a Argentina en el que para mí ya
es sin duda alguna el grupo de la muerte
de este mundial
o vaya celebrar con los tunecinos que
mañana le espera otra jornada de cuatro
partidos
Gracias de Omar Mira por cierto sobre lo
de los cuatro partidos se fue el primer
día que tuvimos cuatro encuentros en
este mundial no podemos llegar al
tercero por las dificultades de
movilidad Cuando llegamos literalmente
no había transporte para llegar a ese
partido de Francia Australia vamos a ver
mañana es uno de los grandes retos como
hemos dicho en varias emisiones que
tiene Qatar ver qué tanto permite llegar
a los aficionados al menos hasta mínimo
dos y hasta tres encuentros en este
mundial
el resultado de ese partido va a dejar
Arabia Saudita como líder inesperado del
grupo c hablamos del resultado del
partido
de Polonia y México quedan nivelados en
el segundo lugar y Argentina en el foso
el otro empate sin goles fue un partido
entre túnez y Dinamarca en el regreso de
Cristian eriksen con su selección
Octavio que podemos comentar de este
resultado donde además hubo también dos
goles anulados Sí sí la mejor noticia
por un lado es el regreso de ericks en
la vida le dio una segunda oportunidad
de umario hoy tiene la posibilidad de
jugar el mundial de representar a su
país y de estar vivo metido en la fiesta
del fútbol eso ya es una gran noticia no
solo para él sino para todo el mundo que
que miró hoy el partido y lo otro es
sorprendente la forma en como túnez le
manejó el partido a Dinamarca durante un
muy buen rato fijémonos Cómo es el
fútbol llegaba mejor Dinamarca que
Francia luego de la actuación de la liga
de Naciones para ambos Dinamarca incluso
logró ganarle a Francia en la Liga de
Naciones Dinamarca había mostrado mucho
mejor fútbol que el equipo campeón del
mundo y aún así Dinamarca se vio estéril
ante lo que le propuso túnez le quitó la
pelota eh eh digamos le trató de
controlar el partido y eso realmente Es
una muy buena noticia al final Dinamarca
se va incómodo y túnel se va Armando un
gran negocio porque se llevó un punto
del partido más difícil Francia es el
líder cómodo decíamos del grupo de con
una diferencia de goles que será muy
valiosa para el futuro por delante de
daneses y tunecinos y Cristiano Ronaldo
va a disputar este mundial sin Club una
de las grandes figuras de Qatar 2022 se
queda sin equipo en plena copa como se
esperaba el Manchester United ha
anunciado que llegó un acuerdo con el
jugador para su salida inmediata esto a
raíz de la entrevista en la que criticó
tanto al técnico erictenhab como a la
familia glazer propietarios del equipo
si bien se podía anticipar esta decisión
no deja de ser inusual ver a una figura
y un club de este Calibre en una
situación así como llegamos a este punto
solamente un tema de Rosa entre un
jugador a su equipo o hay algo más
detrás se quebró toda la relación es
decir uno podía prever como bien lo dice
jehomar que esto estaba terminado que
iba en cualquier momento a pasar lo que
lo que terminó pasando lo que uno no
podía esperar era que en medio del
mundial Y antes del debut de Portugal se
tomara esa decisión ahí Los Dueños del
club le pasan factura evidentemente
Cristiano Ronaldo es decir Cristiano
Ronaldo es un emblema y una leyenda del
Manchester United eso no va a cambiar
deportivamente hablando y
estadísticamente hablando no va a
cambiar pero los dueños del equipo hoy
no les interesa que se siga hablando del
club Y por esa razón cortaron de una vez
sin importarles que el jugador esté en
medio de la Copa del Mundo evidentemente
Cristiano Ronaldo no tiene problemas
económicos no va a tener problemas
seguramente para para conseguir un club
a partir de ahora la noticia es Con qué
equipo va a jugar Cristiano Ronaldo Cuál
va a ser el futuro de este jugador pero
sin duda alguna es una noticia que que
marca muchísimo porque nadie podía
imaginar que en medio de esto cristiano
podía quedarse sin equipo ahí se rompió
no solo la relación con el técnico sino
con sus compañeros con la directiva y
con la gente que maneja el club y que
termina siendo problema para que él no
esté más en Manchester United Octavio
Mil gracias por este aporte seguimos
mañana un abrazo y nosotros los
invitamos a continuar con la
programación de Francia 24 hasta aquí
esta misión de Diario del mundial pero
seguimos con la programación de France
24 en español
[Música]